so here we are at the the Bratislava
language soothing polyglot gathering is
now over and the organizer is Lydia
Lydia Markova and she has just been our
whirlwind of of energy trying to smile
to all her friends while worrying about
all the details and so Fran's on but
let's not talk about the ideas let's
talk about what was achieved what what
is the significance you know I have
trouble explaining to people aren't
going to a polyglot conference what
here's a polyglot conference these just
sort of freaks and geeks that you know
specialize in learning a bunch of
languages hi what's your impression what
did you achieve in a way and I think
that's what's beautiful about it
actually I think the real achievement of
this thing is that the community is
being built and strengthened so many of
many of the people here attended
previous volleyball gatherings or other
events and now they met again together
and you could see when they met the
first days like hey haven't seen you in
a long time and of course they said it
in all possible languages and and now
you see them leaving and there's new
friendships and new people who know each
other and that's that's just so
beautiful and as a first-time
participant although I was at the
Montreal you know long fest it's
wonderful to see the spirit to see the
number of people who speak so many
languages I think that I'm a bit of an
exception but actually I'm not an
exception here I'm very much the norm
and what always strikes me is no and I
before I get into that I wanted to say
there are some very interesting
presentations presentations about
subject of learning languages there is a
discussion about how Bratislava used to
be a trilingual city and of course for
various political and historical reasons
that's no longer the case and so you
learn about the country and I've
discovered more about Slovakia so
languages lead us to discoveries of
other things whether it be food or
history and so forth which is lovely but
but what I wanted to ask you is there
are so many people here who are so good
at so many languages it tells me that
that they're not exceptional you can't
have that many people who are born
exceptional right so therefore in the
general population
in fact there must be a lot of people
who could also learn three if not 30
like Richard but three languages how do
we move from this group of totally
dedicated learners to removing some of
the barriers that prevent your average
person who wants to learn who maybe has
been going to the local community center
Spanish class for seven years and hasn't
made any progress and has stagnated and
is frustrated so how do you how do you
get some of those people to to take
advantage of what we experience here
yeah it's a great question I think the
answer to that is that we look at people
who speak a lot of languages and really
take an example from them mm-hmm in
meaning that as you said it cannot be
that these are just super talented
special people it's very few of them and
they happen to meet all here it shows us
that languages can be learned and I
personally believe that the way
languages are taught and learned out
there is not a very effective way and my
your language coach yourself right and
you don't tie yourself mentally you
don't call yourself a teacher you call a
commander so what does that mean that
means that I don't teach anyone I help
people learn and I believe this is
exactly the thing that all these people
out here do differently they don't wait
for someone to to spoon-feed them the
language but they they really learn
themselves they spend the time with the
language they find the resources
themselves and they find a way how to
enjoy language learning as you or you
help them find resources presumably yes
yes a long way I mean I in the way that
I show them a great choice of resources
and the people pick what they like mm-hm
and they often ask me like how do I know
what are on the visual type or audio
type and I tell them well try it out for
a few minutes and you will tell me if
you like it if you do it's a resource
for you if you don't then go for
something else right and I mean I
certainly that's my philosophy if they
enjoy the process if they enjoy what
they're doing they'll stay with it and
they'll have success and so you've been
able to develop a core group of learners
that you help as a mentor not as a
teacher and they accept the concept
because the reason I say that is if you
because be
typically our condition just to think I
need a teacher yes so you say well no
you don't need you charm your mentor how
do you get over that this is exactly the
difference because when you when you
tend to think I need a teacher
you actually think I need to pay someone
to teach me in the language so all I do
is I pay the money that's my
contribution and the teacher teaches me
because they have the knowledge right
but it's a skill language learning is a
skill is not knowledge that someone
getting murdered I agree that so that's
why I always tell people if you if you
don't understand that you cannot learn
yourself and I cannot help you so that's
why I don't have a solution for everyone
right right I wait for people to
understand that you have to want to
learn yourself and then I can help you
find a way which is best for you
and what's the age group then of the
people you help oh all ages really of
youngest would be um thirteen fourteen
okay no and all these people after 60 70
even is it's beautiful to see how how
they really find the passion for the
language and after 20 years of being an
eternal beginner really suddenly make
progress because they don't just go to
the lesson twice a week but actually
learn at home right right so beautiful
just and that's what you have to do
twice a week grinders go we're not gonna
do it exactly anyway I think there's
something magic here I remember when
Judith started this in Berlin some years
ago or even I guess Richard even earlier
with the polyglot conferences and I just
I didn't really see what it was and I
wasn't that enthusiastic I didn't come
as you know yeah and then I experienced
much here all which I enjoyed and this
one which is even better
and then the next North American event
will be the lawn fest in Montreal that
you're coming absolutely we have some
exciting people coming to that and I
think people should who maybe aren't yet
devoted language learners if they're
near a place where one of these polyglot
conference is being held if in Europe of
course then the nearby or in North
America in Montreal they should come and
we would certainly look forward to
seeing yeah all of you in Montreal yeah
okay and we will change the world
yes okay that everyone loves learning
language
there you go thank you very much city
and thank you very much for organizing
this wonderful wonderful conference
thank you okay
[Music]